dis-moi l'option tu as une histoire
tu sais que les gars ont pensé je
veux commencer une danse d'une
compagnie de danse underground c'est différent tu te fais
prendre à danser tu vas en prison je veux que
nous prenions le contrôle de nos vies j'ai
quelqu'un c'est la nôtre ou  nous pouvons le créer
normal comment le ferions-nous nous devrions
garder le secret juste besoin d'un tranquillement
quelque chose hors du temps c'est parfait
donc c'est la piscine de danse relax
personne d'autre ne sait puis-je auditionner
le régime nous étrangle nous '  re
suffoquant vient du rassemblement oui oui
cela fait de vous un non-croyant il est temps
de changer nous devons faire une danse debout
peut être n'importe quoi qui fait signe au revoir ou se
sent déprimé pour prier ou lève le
poing en l'air parce que vous croyez en
quelque chose que vous  m'a appris
que rien ne devrait arriver à un
public, le regard est une chose pour nous de
pratiquer ici, mais c'était pour montrer
maintenant pourquoi personne ne peut nous voir danser alors
où pourrions-nous mettre en scène une
belle mort de Minerva donc je ne
comprends jamais ça
Je suis  sans ennuis s'ils connaissent votre
nom, ils trouveront que je connais Dieu au
bureau, nous pouvons ressentir ce que c'est que de
respirer juste pendant quelques heures juste pour un
instant même c'est tout ce que je veux